hey you're describing sailing to a
former squid [ __ ] stop stop him what do
we got
military types poking around late deans
guys yep son of a [ __ ]
looks like they found an old colony
outpost but the wrong one right that's
the good news that means it's bad news
only route to the volcano is straight
too
we'll have to drop off
what's the play here Nathan
just follow my lead
let's go gentlemen
how's it yeah that dungus hooked up yet
we're all set up
just waiting on approval from needing to
blow it good place looks empty
I'd like to get it over with and move on
how long we post the down till orders
come in any news from the other side
nothing yet
can we call them and let them know we're
ready or desire to sit tight so we sit
tight you handle explosives I only grew
up everyone in the street it's a good
thing you're not in charge
you
what nothing of the day I talked to me
man
morning boys
Kenard that
push up on it back to the car come on
target fail now the persistent [ __ ]
out there Mon come on
hey we're sitting ducks in this thing
what agreed hang on
you